[Music]
in the heart of Britain there is a place
where they know a thing or two about
resilience about community spirit one
quote from the picking show it's 9:00 in
the morning
on who knows what day for the volunteers
of this Food Bank each seems to roll
into the other at the moment we're in
Coventry in a warehouse where two
organizations have come together the
Trussell Trust is used to getting food
out to those who can't afford it but now
as well they must get it to those two
vulnerable to leave their homes the
donations are sorted boxed loaded and
away the destination is across the city
the good neighbors project is the
initiative of an organization called
simply hope the volunteers here are in
full swing they've been in overdrive
since the lockdown began what's driven
you to come down here and help out the
voice got me involved so why not well
give more time or I'll give myself up to
help people with a system they call
hub-and-spoke they fan out into the city
a lot of parcels to be delivered today
um can I call you back I'm just dropping
off some food at the moment this is
Jackie
on her way to deliver a food parcel to a
man called Ali he's blind
imagine that reliant on touch and yet in
an environment all around us where that
could be lethal to everybody around the
country or who is watching this thanks
ever so much for helping people like
myself and other vulnerable people
during this difficult time up the road
the police are out
what a sign of these Corona times this
is nada Raza has a wife and three
children to support in lockdown at home
and he has three employees to support at
his shop which must remain open because
he has a community to provide for and a
living to make these are the
multi-layered conundrums of this
challenging time are you worried about
your business yeah that's going over
sand birth yeah then maybe next week
wound up then this one maybe this flows
the old cathedral stands here as a
memorial of the Blitz destroyed on one
night of bombing in 1940 they thought it
would break the spirit of the city
instead the opposite happened out of
this came hope it stands still as a
reminder of survival and of renewal
linking those past struggles with today
is that perhaps somehow not quite the
appropriate comparison well the
community spirit and the determination
which rose from here back then is
without question here again today in
abundance the human desire for company
for being together for supporting each
other for being supported by others is
so deep and so powerful that it's
finding a way of overcoming the distance
which has been enforced upon us by this
virus I think in wartime you had the
same sort of experience we're having
today a deep desire for connectedness
for togetherness a spirit of help I
would put it rising in the city and also
a spirit of hope
on the road south Chris Merrett is
keeping food shops in the smaller town
stocked delivery drivers have always
been key it's just that now they are
recognized we drive past now we get the
thumbs up from people we get people
Pippin you know so you know it's a
privilege
Chris's route takes him through a place
where lock downs and pandemics have been
part of history stratford-upon-avon
shakespeare's birthplace quiet and shut
today just like it was 500 years ago
because an outbreak of the plague began
here in this in the first victim Oliver
Gunn died inside his death certificate
carries the words here begins the plague
it's in a registry office that today is
only open for people to register the
dead on the edge of the town at the
Shakespeare hospice Jenna Norris is one
of a team of palliative care nurses
comforting those at the end of their
life well we're just following nurse
Jenna now as she begins her day of home
visits it's gonna be a long day for her
and for many others and it's occurred to
me that as we as a society have focused
a lot on hospitals we focused less on
nurses who are making these in
all-important home visits as a
palliative care nurse and we're normally
very tactile with our patients and their
families and we use touch a lot as a
method of comfort so for example like
you said giving someone a hug or hold in
their hand and not being able to do that
at the moment is really really hard
down on the Aven this was supposed to be
the setting for a big Easter fundraiser
for the struggling hospice of course
that didn't happen
Nick birch organizer of the fundraiser
an owner of a van boating has furloughed
all his staff we meet on what should be
the first week of his tourist season
instead now he's wondering what next
we're all concerned about the business
and the outcome and a lot of unknowns at
this point how long it's going to go on
how long we can maintain our reserves
what we will need to borrow how much and
when and how much that will cost a lot
of unknowns that no but you've got to
take it bit by bit keep a stiff upper
lip I suppose further south
shakespeare's country gives way to the
Cotswolds and fields farmed by four
brothers from an old family of vegetable
growers that drink waters they have
never known it so busy from the farm
shop a home delivery service has been
set up in just days hello there I would
shake your hand but we can't we can't
how are you I'm mark a local family
supporting the local community with
local produce the world will never be
the same again after Corona and I think
people there are some fantastic ideas
out there where if we ever get over this
which we will the world has to change I
look at life differently now to what I
did six weeks ago it's made me realize
actually what I have here baby
the corona virus will actually some good
of it will come in the end and it will
make people realize the fact that we
have to look after the planet for not
only for our children but Fred
children's children